يتيح الفحص بالموجات فوق الصوتيه للاباء
فرصه التعرف اكثر على الجنين في رحم امه
فتعطيهم معلومات عن حجم الجنين وعن مراحل
تقدم العمر كما يبين لهم جنس الجنين ان
كان صبيا او فتاه الا ان مجموعه من
الباحثين قالوا انهم تمكنوا من التوصل الى
اليه اختبارات جديده من شانها ان تكشف
المخطط الجيني الكامل للجنين وهو في رحم
امه ويتم ذلك عن طريق اخذ عينه من دم الام
واخرى من لعاب الاب وفحصه ويمكن من خلال
هذه الفحوصات التعرف على مرض متلازمه داون
حيث تمثل هذه الاختبارات انطلاقه جديده
للتمكن من كشف اكثر من 3 الاف نوع من
الامراض وتسليط الضوء على الطفرات الجينيه
كامك كانيه مقاومه الطفل لمحاربه
السرطان اذا افترضنا ان الجين عباره عن
كتاب وان الشخص العادي لديه نسختين من كل
فصل الكشف عن متلازمه داون في هذا النوع
من الاختبار هو محاوله لتحديد ما اذا كان
هناك نسخه اضافيه من فصل كامل وتمكن هذه
التكنولوجيا من تحديد الاخطاء في الصفحه
الواحده الا ان تلك الاليه الجديده من
الاختبارات ربما تصل تكلفتها الى ما يقرب
من 50 الف دولار لكل اختبار كما انها تثير
مجموعه من التساؤلات الاخلاقيه حيث يمكن
ان تؤدي الى انتقاء ايجابي كما يمكن
الاباء من تحديد صفات معينه في الاطفال
الذين لم يولدوا بعد وفي تعليق للجنه
الوطنيه للحق في الحياه التي ابدت
انزعاجها من تلك الدراسه
الحياه في بدايه الحمل مجرد كلمه تصويريه
والسؤال الوحيد هو ما اذا كانت هذه الحياه
جديره بالحمايه والجواب هو انه لا ينبغي
قتل الارواح وتقطيع اوصالها لاي سبب كان
بعض الطفرات الجينيه تشير الى ان الجنين
قد يولد معاقا ولكن الطفرات الاخرى وهي
العينه الاقل تشير الى ان الجنين ربما
يكون لديه قدر اكبر من الاضطرابات ولكن
كثيرا من الباحثين امثال شينور قالوا ان
هناك انع
هائله واذا قرر الاطباء التعرف في وقت
مبكر على الطفل سيتم وضع شروط طبيه معينه
ويتم التدخل في وقت
مبكر